So I'm tasked with talking about liquid biopsies, not for genotyping or MRD, but as expression
profiling platforms.
Just as a matter of business, these are my disclosures.
So when we talk about liquid biopsies, we can talk about a lot of different molecules,
but some of the molecules of interest are DNA and RNA molecules that are shed from normal
and malignant tissues into the circulation, and that can give us a non-invasive window
into both health and disease.
From a tube of blood, the plasma compartment can be studied to find DNA aberrations in
genomic lesions, epigenetic landscape, some emerging methods.
I'll talk about fragmentomic features, and then finally, gene expression, inferred and
direct, and we'll be talking about that aspect.
So what's been done so far, these are two kind of canvassing landscape-type papers.
The first is a paper in Nature from a group in Israel using whole genome bisulfite sequencing
and looking at cell-free nucleic acids to see what the composition is, but it's not
so important to look at the pie chart and figure out.
It's important to look at what the exact proportions are, but simply getting an idea
that liquid biopsies can give us a window into many different cell types, including
non-hematopoietic ones.
On the right is another study from Stanford, from Steve Quake's group, looking at cell-free
RNA and whole transcriptome profiling.
Again, the pie has many slices that aggregate the experience of tissue homeostasis from
many different organs.
So what's been done with these kinds of technologies?
One thing that you may have heard about is the idea of multi-cancer early detection,
a drop of blood in tests for many cancer types.
What are some of the key studies in this space?
One is called the Pathfinder study.
This was a study led by Grail using the GALERI methylation-based multi-cancer early detection
test, and testing average-risk adults.
The study was done in the United States, and it was done in the United States.